I have said time and time again if we
don't get this issue dealt with then the
British public will
they will end up taking matters into
their own hands take Northern Ireland as
a prime example militias will be set up
and then the UK government will have a
problem beyond their wildest dreams
in action we'll only facilitate the
creation of a disgruntled and angry
population who will end up cleaning out
this Islamic problem cleaning out this
Islamic problem cleaning out this
Islamic problem
so I just got here
so I just got here to the scene
uh Musa and the others
should be here we're just gonna go and
try to interview
uh eyewitness and see what happened
whoever does terrorism has to be called
a terrorist by the media of this country
what's happening right now what seems to
be the case the media is not calling it
a terrorist attack what really amazes me
London Bridge attack within minutes yeah
here it's been nearly two hours as to
why this is not being called a terrorist
attack one report States from Sky News
vehicle collides with pedestrians in
Finsbury Park okay the independent
similarly
van hits pedestrians near Finsbury Park
Mosque in London this is not what this
is not what was happening with London
Bridge I've got another question is
yes exactly exactly it was an accident
you don't need so much police here no
not to block the roads it's very clear
that this was something very very very
serious big what happens innocent people
get killed Isis and these foreign groups
have something in common terrorism even
even the methods of the British party
non-muslim and non-muslim have something
in common they are both victimized to
this kind of attacks so so sorry last
time I want to ask you again you're
clear that the guy was driving on the
road and then he went into people so you
saw that happen 100 no 100 you saw that
happen the guy was on the road straight
and then he went into yeah and he saw
the Target and he hit
one thing is very very clear is that
when Isis preach hate you have innocent
people being killed British non-muslim
public being killed when you have
individuals like Tommy Robinson Rebel
media daily mayo and Nigel farage Katie
Hopkins and Britain first when they
preach hate innocent people also die
this time Muslims right now they there's
something that we really need to grasp
you and understand there's a fine line
we have this fine line on the other side
we have Isis preaching hate innocent
people being killed then we have on the
uh the same side you get the Tommy
Robinson the Britain first Rebel media
Nigel farage and Katie Hopkins and Daily
Mail these individuals preach the same
hate and what has happened let's look at
the same results innocent people being
killed so if we look onto the left-hand
side here we can see that the killing of
innocent British people be Muslim or
non-muslim so you can see a pattern he
preaches innocent people being killed do
you not think that is a bit strange why
dimensional media is not calling this a
terrorist attack when if we all know if
a Muslim did this which we have a few
weeks ago it was immediately within
minutes labeled a terrorist attack
without any evidence possible it was
immediately made with a terrorist attack
but so far as as far as I know not a
single mainstream media and
I knew that my my son was in there okay
so you actually did you you your son was
here he was in the mosque yeah okay is
he safe now no he's just his mom just
called me and I was like he's safe
because the captain
okay how does that make you feel like
because I feel real if you know yeah
because I was worried yeah I was in tea
because when you don't I mean you don't
know the first of your son but I was in
a hospital or injured and something
could happen how many people said were
in the van do you think in the van in
the van
again
the road but he came to the left and
allowed with a beaver is in there's no
way to put that side
it's just a 2-3 parking it's only for
three parkings small Road it's not even
uh just a road it's just uh
parking space do you think you
deliberately drove into people he was
deliberately driving to the people 100
did he shout anything when he wanted to
play uh just it was fleeing by he didn't
say nothing just I was fighting because
he kicking the people who just outside
and catch him lucky can I see yeah
that's the picture of him
can you show the photo once more please
brothers and sisters and dear friends uh
hope you guys are doing well we are here
at the scene uh I was at home sleeping I
got a call from Brother Mohammed hijab
he told me that this happened
um obviously I was a bit dazed out first
but I heard what happened I went
straight on to Facebook and I saw a live
feed from one of the brothers and I saw
that Musa Musa and Adnan Rasheed was
here on the scene
um one thing that I really want to
mention is uh that sadly sadly when
before I was coming it'll start I was
just reading the the news articles yeah
and it says a white man plunges into the
pedestrians
um in front of a mosque and they
mentioned this hate preacher yeah they
go uh what's his name
yeah I just read I was really curious I
was like no we can read the headline
here right now word by word it states
yeah Daily Mail has reported yes
white van driver injures at least 10
people after plowing into a crowd
outside London's Finsbury Park Mosque
where hate cleric Abu Hamza once
preached as Muslims finish their evening
prayer okay the question that needs to
be asked why did they have to mention
this hate clerk what's that got to do
with anything
I think they deliberately did this uh to
take any sympathy away from the victims
even though the victims were innocent
people they were simply out to pray and
they came out of the mosque to after
finishing the prayer Abu Hamza was here
more than 10 years ago and he wasn't
even in this mosque yes we have been
told it was another mosque where he was
preaching yeah so the reason why this
race yeah yeah of course the reason why
this hateful hate-mongering newspaper uh
worded the the the the headline like
that is to take away any sympathy from
the Muslims who were victimized in fact
this headline appears to be sympathizing
with the culprit yes that what he did
was write well done for killing Muslims
in a mosque where a hate preacher Once
Upon a Time preached mainstream media in
Britain is deliberately playing down uh
this incident which was clearly a
terrorist attack how do we know this
because the tactic used was exactly the
the tactic used by Isis attackers there
was one in France who plowed his truck
into people there was one on London
Bridge these uh an unfortunate
individuals that drove into the
pedestrians here we have a case where
white individuals white males yeah it
was three of them two escaped one was
arrested they plowed their van in to the
Muslim crowd and I spoke to an
eyewitness he confirmed it that yes he
has no doubt that this was a deliberate
attack on innocent Muslims coming out of
the mosque and I asked him clearly
whether he saw the van change course and
he said yes the van the van was on the
road and then it swerved into yes the
Muslims and there was three of them it
were three of them and they caught one
the driver and the other two are on the
Run Okay so Brothers thank you
so brother sisters what more can we say
what more can we say so brothers and
sisters this is all that I had to say
I'm here you can go to brother Musa he
was here before me he's got the full
footage everything that happened do
check his channel out do subscribe and
watch the full video inshallah and share
this with your friends and family and
share this with your non-muslim friends
because we're not going to come to you
and say hey we want every white
individual to come and condense attack
no because terrorism has no religion
I mean